Tyger why I had no real plan to review
this movie and the more you heard about
it the more I wanted to say it so aside
I guess now I'm gonna talk about the
edge of seventeen ever those of you
who've been asking them for the past few
videos that I've done I've been sick
like really I just II cold that's
made my voice lower and more raspy I
let's hope we're going for sexy John's
voice here it's just sick made up uh on
with the review so the age of seventeen
is a coming-of-age story starring Hailee
Steinfeld the series of events have
happened in her life has led to her
being kind of a standoffish awkward
she's she's in high school a lot of
people myself included we're all awkward
in high school she's brash like awkward
it's the perspective of the person in
high school who would spend their
lunches in the teacher's classroom
eating lunch in an empty classroom as a
teacher I did that in tenth grade in the
height of my awkwardness I was watching
the movie was like oh my god I did that
at the age of seventeen is it's a
coming-of-age story starring a girl
which made me go I'm not gonna relate to
this movie I just it's not going to be
me shows what I know cuz the movies
actually pretty sweet it's hard to
explain to people wise because it's
coming-of-age story starring a girl in
high school who's awkward and dude don't
worry guys you're totally gonna relate
to this movie and then she has a friend
and there's tension that grows between
those two but don't worry guys you're
going to relate to the mood I can't
describe the movie that will tell guys
out there that they can relate to this
movie I'm Downton Abbey the whole thing
yeah you know you know people who watch
Downton Abbey and they try to explain it
to you like a no there's no way
that's clicking for me but apparently
everyone loves Downton Abbey that that's
this movie age of 17 is completely
relatable to everybody if you've gone
through high school that is but I'd
swear it'll click for you Hailee
Steinfeld was great in this movie I mean
she was great in true great we knew that
that girl is going to be the star as a
girl as of Dallas we didn't know how
much talent then I saw her in pitch
perfect - I didn't I wasn't really a fan
of pitch perfect - I thought she was
good in it I was interested to see where
she would go this movie right here holy
this girl has great comedic timing
delivery the dialogue is just written in
a very realistic way delivered in a
perfect way Woody Harrelson's in this
movie he's great he's a teacher
pretty much talks to his students and
her especially like I respond to idiot
tweets on Twitter you have to just look
at it you're like I'm going to give you
solid sarcasm right now because you're
being dumb and I really love that
because you know every teacher wants to
say that and they can so their only
outlet is hoping that a movie
illustrates that in a well-written way
well-executed way for them and now they
have that that's what I mean by everyone
can relate to this movie this movie's
coming-of-age story for sure and it
really does illustrate and show that the
coming-of-age thing was awkward for
everybody
male-female in high school which really
shows us that we're all just part of the
same compost heap really you think
you're special you are not special you
were not a beautiful and unique
snowflake if you were awkward in high
school so were a lot of other people
people showed it in different ways
people dealt with it in different ways
and I really loved that it really does
bridge the gap when I say everybody I
mean everybody I mean if you're an older
brother you'll get this movie if you're
a younger sibling you'll get this movie
if you're a parent you'll get this movie
for a teacher you'll get this movie if
you're a douche bag it there's a spot in
here for you but the movie was really
sweet it really was in a way that it's
hard to find a coming-of-age story that
you might see as like the Ferris
Bueller's Day Off for today's generation
tope was one that we got recently that I
thought was great I think it's great
that this generation has this movie as
predictable as the movie is undeniably
every third situation I'm like this
situations going to end like this it did
the next situations all is gonna end
like this dead but it's not about the
predictability and it's not about the
outcome it's about the path two guys in
the end the age of 17 was truly a bridge
builder it really was I went in this
movie gun I'm not gonna relate to a
coming-of-age story from a girl in high
school at all my problems were different
than her problems holy so my
problems were the same as their problems
because teenagers generally speaking see
every situation under one lens and that
is the sky is falling and it's just it's
not always so you don't have to make it
that and the movies funny - I got to
address that between the writing the
execution among the actors in the
situational circumstances the movie is
quite hysterical and not only is it
funny but it blends comedy and drama was
such synergy in a way that a lot of
movies try to do but very few movies
actually end up succeeding it do it I
want to see more from this director I
want to see more from Hailee Steinfeld
and I will say the edge of seventeen is
worth watching
I strongly recommend buying it on
blu-ray I feel like I might love this
movie more as time goes on who knows by
the time I do my top ten of the year
I've no idea how it's going to go down I
can see this movie aging like a fine
wine but as I stand right now that's my
review and that's what I'm sticking with
so the edge of seventeen have you seen
it what did you think about it what's
your favorite coming-of-age story Empire
Strikes Back counts
yes but it's so obvious you gotta go
with something else whatever it is
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more